for a wild card race that starts today
with the blue jays the mariners the
boston red sox and the new york yankees
all in the hunt for a birth into the
postseason and what a big moment for the
rookie alec manoa 20th start of his
season he picked up the the win his last
time out his eighth of the season
infield back outfield with a gap open
swing and a miss on a 2-2 two up in two
down to the first strikeout of the
afternoon for alec manoa it doesn't
appear as if there's an ounce of nerves
in alec manoa the bigger the game the
more excited he is
and he's off to a terrific start this
afternoon a one two three first getting
to work for alec manoa blue jays are
going to win they're going to have to
beat the baltimore orioles best pitcher
this is john means blue jays haven't
seen him this year the 1-2 pitch there's
a swing and a line drive into left field
sinking quickly hayes has to play it on
a bounce it's down for a basic and that
will stop springer with a lead off
single and now vladimir guerrero jr and
the pitch is drilled deep left field
that ball is gone
a majestic
soaring
two-run home run
off the 300 level
from vladimir guerrero jr
number 47 for vladi it matches a major
league record for big league ball
players 22 years of age or younger he
ties eddie matthews
1953 major league mark with 47 home runs
to oscar hernandez has not quite been
himself in recent days over his last 14.
maybe he can get going
i think he answered your question
i think he's ready he was fooled on that
first pitch but he didn't miss the
second one wow now two guys who have
done so much for the team this year that
goes without saying guerrero and
hernandez but again quiet offensively
the last few days making a whole lot of
noise here in the bottom of the first
battle back last night when they got in
a hole as mancinio stand in the pitch
and he swings and rifles one down the
left field line it's a fair ball it'll
bounce its way into the corner trey
turns first heads to second base and
he's going to stop there with a lead off
double against manoa mancini jumped on a
pitch early on the count and he blasted
it down the line so it's an out but it's
a productive one for gutierrez sliding
mancini down an additional 90 feet and
with one out mckenna will come up all no
strikes to ryan mckenna
that's hit hard to the second baseman
mancini will score on the out and the
orioles are on the board so give ryan
mckenna an rbi and it's a 3-1 toronto
league so a man on with nobody out for
danny jansen janssen hitting 3-27 since
he came off the il and now he drills one
down the left-field line that's a fair
ball aspinall on his way to third the
throw comes in towards third and jansen
takes it advantage by getting into
second quality at bat here
rips that ball one down second and third
george springer at the plate
springer fly ball left field
well hit
a three-run homer for george springer
and it is 6-1 george springer will join
the 20 home run club as the blue jays
are wearing out that jacket
so far this afternoon
i hope they wear it out that they have
to go clean it up
third home run already and he didn't
wait around
one ball and two strikes on richie
martin swing and a miss blew a fastball
by him one down that type of fastball
right there told you it's a couple
clicks faster than the last time he was
on the mound two down ryan mount castle
hitter the 2-1 pitch in the air towards
the line bridgeick with the sunglasses
gleaming towards the chalk runs it down
now castle's retired so are the orioles
maybe an issue with the home plate
umpire chris guccione giuccioni has gone
down the tunnel that's mark wegner right
there talking to charlie on the left so
i mean he does not have the gear on and
now it looks like he has sent chris
conroy just now leaving the field to go
get the gear on so we're going to have a
delay for a while well we have a home
plate umpire chris conroy has put the
gear on and he is back out behind the
plate and tabby about a 20-minute delay
slow roller out to the shortstop routine
as it can be to richie martin and he
clanks it two out base runner for
santiago espinal the 3-2
bear ball
espinol does it again
guri ellen to score on an rbi double it
is 7-1 3-2 change-up hot hitter rips it
down the left field line to get another
run for the blue jay lead off man on
trey mancini at the plate the 1-2 swing
and a miss he's down on strikes
strikeout number four for alec manoa
the o2
slider out the knee strike three called
back-to-back strikeouts for manoa here
in the fourth inning oriole left fielder
ryan mckenna to the plate the 2-2
mckenna swings and misses
alec manoa strikes out the side here in
the fourth minute two down now in this
fifth inning one ball and two strikes on
the batter richie martin
got him
three up three down go the orioles seven
strikeouts on the afternoon for manoa
seven one bottom five boba shetto for
two
drilled to left field
gone
number 29 for bushette and the fourth
home run of the afternoon for the blue
jays
the jacket's getting worn out and i love
it
oh buchet can hit man i don't care what
kind of pitcher it is a guy who throws
96 or 97 a junk baller a curveball i
don't care this guy can handle them all
arielle reached out in air and then
scored a run in the third inning pitch
in
here's a sharp ground ball right side
diving pickup filenka to his feet throws
to first and guriel is out so was hit
sharply but valencia
feeling the worm burner on a dive got to
his feet and threw guriel out two out
single for toronto here in the fifth
inning that'll bring up danny jansen
to right field this one's pretty well
hit how about that
danny jansen with an opposite field home
run and it is 10-1 blue jays
franchise record
258 home runs this season fifth home run
of the game for the blue jays one man
down here in the seventh inning kelvin
gutierrez will come to the plate a
one-two pitch
slider anthony strike three call
gutierrez goes down looking strikeout
number nine for manoa one of his best
performances in the regular season for
alec manoa
well it might be the last pitch that he
throws this afternoon strikeout number
10 for alec manoa absolutely dominant in
this game yankees lost today the red sox
are in action the mariners lost last
night the blue jays are trying to lock
up another win here at rogers center
[Applause]
and another drive is to left center but
it's playable hernandez is there and
that's your ball game the blue jays did
exactly what they had to do today they
won and they won in convincing fashion
they saved some arms they swung the bats
and they'll take the field tomorrow
alive for a playoff spot
you